attempts to publicly shame Trump donors
appear to be backfiring one of the
people called out by a congressman
Joaquin Castro last week is claiming
that he and others have now raised over
a million dollars for President Trump
and new numbers show the president's
campaign is being powered by small
dollar donations over 60% is coming from
donations under $200 this news is not
stopping Democrats from trying to cut
off Trump's fundraising congressman Al
Green suggesting impeachment might be
the way to do it if he is not defeated
in the Senate he will still run as an
impeached president and there will be a
good many people who want one of whole
fundraisers with him a good many people
who won't want to be in his company
because he will become persona non grata
to a good many of these wealthy people
who are benefiting from his bigotry but
Mark going for impeachment could
actually fuel Trump's donor base even
more yeah I mean you know bring it bring
it on lose the the idea that he's going
to be persona non grata to wealthy
donors last time around as this time
around he gets his money in small
donations in a way that Mitt Romney and
John McCain and Republican candidates
usually don't so if some if a couple of
billionaires are embarrassed because
he's impeached big deal he'll still get
his 50 and $100 donations and that's
what he got last time and that's the
difference is that he's not a donor
candidate big difference well he is a
donor candidate this time around well
washing cash because all of those people
who held back they have all given this
time getting on the bandwagon after it's
not that they are holding back now they
are actually everybody is all in
Jedidiah the left has dominated
small-dollar for a long time and they
were able to capitalize on that over and
over again the Republicans finally have
a counter to what the Democrats call act
blue they call it win red and the
president is fully behind it so now
they've got a way to figure out how to
get if you want $20 another $20 another
29 so things like for example the NRS
see I believe made a ton of money on the
Betsy Ross t-shirt right during that
traversing right it's a huge problem
they're not the folks on the left aren't
used to having to deal with candidates
like this on the right this is a huge
ground swelling they're seeing of
grassroots support and that's very
dangerous for competition because that
means that those people are gonna go out
and vote they're gonna those grassroots
supporters get really passionate around
election time and I'm just wondering if
all these left wingers like secretly
speaking of conspiracies they all
secretly work for Trump because their
their their dirt everything that they're
doing and you got Bill Maher out there
calling for a recession that hurts so
many of his viewers who are middle-class
viewers who would be hurt by that
recession you got left wing commentators
calling Trump supporters racists now you
have you know left-wing politicians just
actively going after donors and naming
them so it's like how much I don't know
that they could try any harder to get
Trump elected this is this is a pretty
minute let me grab a Greg in here
because nothing inspires fundraising
more than if you feel like you're being
marginalized or attacked yeah I mean
well number one the other to your point
about their kind of the radical nature
of Trump's machine they already the
Trump pants website already has a Fredo
Cuomo t-shirt up there we're gonna talk
about that in the next block but I
wanted to do a tease look if you're on
the fence about anything you have to
think about what the left is doing they
are sanctioning a domestic trade war
right
they're actually waging a trade war
they're waging a trade war against their
neighbors if you use any product that is
owned or operated by a political party
that isn't yours that makes you
complicit in evil that's what being told
so the left is applying the BDS bigoted
BDS movement to their fellow Americans
that's a trade war that's just gonna
push the marginalized to give more money
to Trump if you continue doing that
people who have never given before and I
wanted the Democrats have benefited from
this type same type of thing remember
when Elizabeth Warren give the big
speech on the floor and makaan Mitch
McConnell asked her to yield and then
nevertheless she persisted remember that
thing the Democrats made so much money
off of those t-shirts right but I think
we've taken our eyes away from the
reality what's going on here the reality
is that the President had a two-year
jump on everybody in terms of
fundraising and he doesn't have really a
primary challenge so he
has that advantage the Democrats have
been raising money the big money for
Trump is like this weekend in the
Hamptons where it was 250,000 dollars a
ticket and that's typical special is now
yes and typical of you know after
citizens united the amount of outside
money that's flowing Trump has a huge
lead over the Democrats from big donors
who don't necessarily identify they come
through the PACs they come through these
private but yeah but I just think that
we've now to say oh what Trump has a
surge in terms of these small donors the
small donors are being drawn in by
things like straws or t-shirts and the
like having a but the big money up the
big money still comes from guys who say
you know what I got that tax break
I got a huge tax break and Thank You
Donald Trump a lot of people didn't get
that repeal salt